everyone.
We're going to come around here and we're gonna go up around here and we're going
we're going to WWDC.
Okay,
so I'm a little out of practice with people and in person Apple events since I've been watching from
my basement for two years.
But I'm here,
I did it.
I'm at Apple's worldwide developers conference to watch the keynote on this
screen tim.
Is it okay with you if I wear slippers?
Okay,
I promised this video is not about my first time back at an in person Apple event.
It's about the two hour prerecorded keynote,
Apple held to announce updates to IOS 16.
Let's talk about watch OS this year in ipad Os 16 we have
a big release Mako West ventura enriches so many of the ways we use our max,
just like every year there are hundreds of new software updates coming to your Apple gadgets this
fall.
And Apple also threw in a new hardware upgrade and all new Macbook Air completely
redesigned around them to here are the eight announcements.
I'm most excited about Number one,
a new macbook air introducing Mhm that's
right.
New laptop,
new chip.
The Air has a new M two chip which is as you guessed it a lot faster
according to charts,
it delivers 18% greater performance.
But I'm more excited about the total redesign of this £2.7 Fanless laptop.
It's been totally slimmed down and like the Macbook Pros.
It brings back the Magsafe charging connector.
Oh wow,
that's really,
really light.
It will not drop this and of course colors,
silver space gray,
a gorgeous Starlight and a stunning midnight.
It's not your old Macbook air either.
Yes,
it's got a notch surrounding the new 10 80 P webcam and a slightly larger
13 inch screen.
Overall the best part might be the optional power adaptor.
It has two USB C ports so you can plug in your iphone or other gadget and
simultaneously charge both.
This one comes with the higher end 14 99 Macbook Air model but you could also upgrade for
$20.
The air will be available in july number to a new iphone lock
screen.
Say bye to your boring lock screen With IOS 16.
You'll be able to change the font and color of the time and date.
I think this looks awesome now.
Plus you can add widgets including weather and with widget kit,
developers can create their own widgets for the lock screen and so you can see all of those.
The notifications now pop up from the bottom of the screen.
Iowa 16 is only available for those with the iphone eight or later.
Sorry,
anyone with an older iphone number three messaging features.
Finally you can now mark any thread as unread.
Okay,
I'm super into this one since I'm constantly forgetting about messages now I'll be able to
mark them as on red and no to come back to them.
Then there are two new features for those times when you flood a message,
you'll be able to edit a message or recall the message entirely.
Now you have undo send but only for up to 15 minutes after sending it.
Number four Pass keys.
No one likes passwords.
But what about past keys passed keys use biometric sensors in your device.
Touch ID face ID to authenticate logins.
That means you don't need to create a password or try to remember it when you make an online account with a
supported device but you'll need an apple device to prove your identity.
We've designed pass keys to work at apps as easily as they do on the web.
Pasties are securely sync across apple devices using iCloud keychain.
We've been working with industry leaders in the Fido alliance,
including Google and Microsoft to ensure that pass keys work seamlessly across
platforms.
If it sounds confusing.
I know,
but this is all an industry effort to work towards a new safer password list.
Standard number five new carplay.
Okay,
so we didn't see an apple car,
but the next version of carplay looks totally awesome.
It basically replaces all the crap from your car maker,
the radio interface,
climate control speedometer,
everything on the dashboard.
In fact,
this next generation of carplay powers your entire instrument cluster
to do this.
Your iphone communicates with your vehicles real time systems in an
on device privacy friendly way except no one is getting
this anytime soon.
Carmakers will need to build it into their new models vehicles will start to be
announced late next year.
Number six medication reminders.
Well the name says it all with watch OS nine and IOS 16.
You'll be able to put your medications into the health app and set reminders to take them.
You can log medications that you might take occasionally,
like severe zine for allergies and you can receive notifications for
medications that you need to take regularly.
You can even use the iphone camera to scan the label of the medication number seven
continuity camera with the new Mac,
os ventura and IOS 16.
You can finally do something I've been doing for the last two years.
Use your iphones camera as your webcam Now for an odd but technically
impressive feature.
It's called desk view and it uses the iphones ultra wide camera to show a bird's eye view of
your desk.
I didn't even need to adjust my phone.
It looks cool.
I mean until you leave out some confidential paper or I don't know your hemorrhoid cream.
Sadly this fancy iphone clip sold separately.
Number eight Stage Manager.
Okay.
Ipad users,
here's another one that will make your tablet more like a real computer with IOS 16 a feature
called Stage Manager will actually let you use ipad apps like Windows.
You can resize them and have them overlap and if you have an ipad Pro or
Air with an M one chip,
you can get full external display support with resolutions up to six K.
Alright,
well I survived going home with my slippers on,
mm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm hmm.